cali bonsoir bonsoir aujourd'hui en
france plus de 60 mille petites filles
sont excisées chaque année
dans le monde 2 millions de petites
filles sont excisées chaque année 130
millions de femmes dans le monde ont
subi ces mutilations qu'a dit vous avez
été mutilés au nom de la tradition et
vous témoigner dans un livre publié chez
oh éditions qui s'intitule tout
simplement mutilé
mutilation dans la petite enfance mais
aussi mariage avant l'adolescence
grossesse avant l'âge adulte au delà de
l'excision votre vie a longtemps été
placée sous le signe de la soumission
pourtant tout commence dans une grande
maison d'infos bourde d'une ville
sénégalaise thiès une ville paisible à
l'ombre de la mosquée une grande famille
une tribu au départ tout va bien au
départ tout va très bien je suis dans
une famille
bien entouré bien choyés vous êtes
heureuse
on est en 1966 vous avez sept ans un
jour les grands mères viennent vous dire
aujourd'hui nous allons te purifier
il est réveillé très tôt douchez
habiller
des dix cousine entre 6 et 9 ans qu'ils
sont là aussi
vous sentez quelque chose de particulier
à ce moment là
à ce moment là nous comme tout petit cri
avait plein de cousine qui était venu en
vacances à la maison où tout allait bien
il ya quand même une dame de la caste
des forgerons qui hélas oui
et elle quand elle arrive je comprends
ce qui va se passer ouais et là votre
grand mère vous annonce que vous allez
être excisées pour pouvoir accéder à la
prière oui le mot dans notre landes veut
dire pouvoir accéder à la prière être
purifiée en fait et surtout
excisées pour arriver vierge au mariage
pour ne pas avoir de rapports sexuels
avant le mariage et
le plus important c'est de rester fidèle
à son mari après alors en fait on on dit
que c'est à cause de la religion mais
c'est pas vrai parce qu en afrique
toutes les religions le fonds ont
finalement toutes les religions
existent aussi le fond à ce moment-là
vous ignorez ce qu'est un clitoris de
toute façon j'ai jamais fait attention à
ça à cette partie de mon corps donc ben
moi je ne saurai jamais c'est quoi un
clitoris
alors c'est terrible la scène il ya deux
femmes qui vous tiennent
ces deux femmes leur visage est effacé
de ma mémoire le seul visage qui était
resté c'est cette femme qui parce
qu'elle fait partie en quelque sorte de
la famille elle est toujours là
donc elle reste et parce que c'est elle
qui coupent aussi ça ça reste toute la
vie ça ça ne s'en va pas mais vous dites
c'est pas si simple finalement elle est
obligée de s'y est carrément non parce
qu'elle a une lame de rasoir elle ne
peut pas couper à vif donc obligé il
faut qu'elle si la branche j'avais cette
image c'est votre sang qui gicle sur son
visage c'est les images qui me sont
restés c'est les images pense qu'il m'a
resteront toute la vie et parce que j'ai
peut-être vu d'autres petites filles
souffrir par ces pratiques avant de
prendre conscience alors cette image
elle reste holà à ce moment-là vous
ressentez une douleur inexplicable vous
croyez un moment que vous êtes morte
presque oui ça c'est certain qu'à ce
moment là je
ne me souviens plus d'être dans ce monde
je pensais que c'était fini parce que je
ne ressentait plus de douleur mais la
douleur et les dans tout le corps
puisque on ne peut plus bouger c'est
comme une des fourmis qui sont à
l'intérieur vous vite c'est une douleur
qui va durer pendant des semaines
quand on coupe une oreille où un doigt
c'était une douleur qui durent longtemps
là c'est une douleur qu dur énormément
de temps parce que tous les matins et
tous les soirs faut soigner faut enlever
le sang qui coagule alors forcément
c'est une douleur qui ne s'en va pas si
facilement
vous dites cette coupure intime qui me
retranche est pour toujours d'une
sexualité normale
forcément forcément forcément parce que
couper la plupart intimement qui est de
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on m'a enlevé
ça et en même temps on m'a mutilée
quelque part dans mon cerveau parce que
le but c'est de me souvenir que je reste
soumise à un homme en particulier
voilà
alors la vie continue six ans plus tard
vous avez 13 ans vous entrée en 6e au
collège
quand une lettre arrive de france un
cousin qui veut vous épousez
oui quand on me l'a annoncé j'ai pas
broncher parce que
l'éducation ne me permettaient pas de
dire oui ou non et parce que tout
simplement dans mon esprit comme dans
l'esprit de beaucoup de petites filles à
l'époque notre but notre destin c'est le
mariage alors quand une de nous se marie
on est tous content tu mets à ce moment
là on ne sait pas ce que c'est que le
mariage ce cousin vous le connaissez pas
non je l'avais jamais vue auparavant
alors le mariage arrive on vérifie votre
virginité on vous est pile toujours
cette fameuse lama rasoir qui vous a
fait tellement mal et vous n'avez
toujours pas toujours pas vu votre mari
je n'ai pas vu parce que le soir
avec tout le tourbillon les jours trop
font la fête et vous on vous emmène dans
la chambre nuptiale et terrorisés j'ai
pas regardé par regardez d'ailleurs
cette nuit c'est complètement effacé de
ma mémoire oui vous dit j'ai le cerveau
bloquer les tables sont de votre propre
vie pendant trois ou quatre heures
pendant toute la nuit j'étais
complètement je n'en reviens pas on se
souvient pas de cette nuit là tout ce
que je me souviens aujourd'hui de cette
nuit c'est les
les tentes les moments qu'ils étaient
contentes et qui exprimaient leur leur
joie par les chants les tam-tams
pendant l'acte sexuel
votre douleur est aggravée par les
séquelles de l'excision certainement
certainement je ne m'en souviens pas du
tout mais certainement puisque je l' ai
ressenti plus tard en cette nuit là vous
pousser un cri terrible que tout le
monde entend aux alentours les copines
me l'ont redit le lendemain mais moi
je ne m'en souviens pas de secret votre
mari vous fait peur oui c'était normal
j'avais 13 ans et demi lui on a 19 ans
de différence
pourtant vous partez avec lui en france
oui je suis arrivé en france un an après
vous voyez quand vous arrivez en france
vous voyez les blancs d'abord j'avais
jamais vu autant vous dites dans votre
livre qui vous trouvez qu'ils ont donnée
pointu
c'était bizarre de voir autant de blancs
autour de moi et qui piaillent et qui
parle et qui
est dans mon pays bon à dakar il y en
avait mais moi j'étais
un peu plus éloigné de dakar donc je
n'en voyais pas beaucoup il ya un truc
terrible c'est que les gens qui ont les
yeux bleus ou les yeux vers vous étonne
beaucoup et les gens qui ont les yeux
vers vous font peur jusqu'à aujourd'hui
j'avoue que j'avais été voir il ya
quelques années un
dentiste elle avait les yeux verts comme
un chat et je suis pas retourné
pourquoi ça veut dire quoi laissez moi
ça me fait peur c'est s'aider yeux d'un
chat c'est tout à fait peur c'est mignon
alors à 16 ans vous accouchez pour la
première fois difficilement penser que
ce soit encore les séquelles de
l'excision qu'a dit oui pour moi il ya
aucun doute c'est les séquelles de
l'excision parce que l'excision quand on
est fermi et
la peau les plastiques à ce moment là
donc à l'accouchement forcément à la
peau soit elle pète où les médecins sont
obligés d'ouvrir de faire des petits
autonomie pour que alors quelques mois
plus tard vous vous retomber enceinte et
vous dites vous expliquer que le devoir
conjugal devient un véritable supplice à
l'époque vous connaissez pas encore le
mot de viol conjugal mais c'est bien de
ça dont vous êtes victimes j'en suis
victime comme des millions de fans je
crois que même en occident le devoir
conjugal était obligatoire il ne fallait
pas penser à soi et penser seulement
donner le plaisir et ne pas en recevoir
un
pourquoi acceptez-vous beau fils soit
excisée à leur tour je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas parce que tout simplement
je pense qu'à l'époque j'étais moi-même
dans le cocon j'étais dans le cercle
familial sous la pression sociale et
familiale et je pensais tout simplement
que ben pour qu'elle puisse être accepté
dans la société il faut qu'elle le soit
alors ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
que parallèlement à cet enfer qu'est
votre vie de couple caddie vous
commencez une formation
vous obtenez un diplôme de mécanographe
être comptable vous trouver un travail
rue du faubourg saint-honoré enfin vous
avez eu un courage extraordinaire c'est
génial oui et ce travail ça m'avait
permis de m'épanouir ça m'avait permis
de voir d'autres personnes de m'ouvrir
et malheureusement par ce travail aussi
commencent les problèmes parce que
je partais toute la journée je revenais
je m'habillais autrement je pensais
autre main par là je commençais à penser
autrement et ça commençait à déranger
alors quand vous prenez la pilule là
c'est fini là votre mari vous traite de
foot moi ça a été la totale ouais mais
vous continuez quand même hein vous
je sais pas je crois que c'est mes
grands-mères qui m'ont donné cette force
parce que c'est des femmes qui m'ont
élevé qui avait la force l'autonomie
dans tout ce qu'elle faisait
même si elle était soumise mais elle
n'était pas il n'y avait pas j'ai pas
elle ne vivait pas comme nous on le vit
aujourd'hui en europe en tout cas alors
un moment votre mari prend une deuxième
épouse évidemment ça vous gêne pas du
tout parce que vous dites comme ça vient
me foute la paix à ce moment là c'est
vrai que j'avais déjà fait mon plan pour
partir mais je me suis gouré sur la
polygamie vous dites en afrique c'est
acceptable mais finalement en europe ça
l'est beaucoup moins parce qu'il ya très
peu d'espacé finalement quand il ya deux
femmes à la maison il y en a une qui
dort dans le lit qu'on sait son tour de
dormir dans le lit et l'autre est obligé
de dormir à la cuisine avec les enfants
donc il ya certaines familles wii qui
ont qui ont vécu à cette époque comme ça
parce que manque de place et même
aujourd'hui malheureusement elles ne
dorment pas dans le même lit mais c'est
les enfants qui trinquent parce que la
chambre des enfants pour le donner à la
polygamie ici en europe c'est dommage
parce que il n'y a pas assez de place et
c'est toujours évidemment les femmes qui
paient on ne sait même pas pourquoi on
accepte c'est notre éducation c'est tout
mais bon moi je ne pouvais pas je peux
je peux pas supporter donc j'ai préféré
plier bagage en fait vous dit que le but
des hommes c'est de faire des enfants à
la chaîne pour toucher les allocations
familiales c'est une espèce de nouvel
esclavage finalement
on est de toute façon des esclaves
on est des esclaves mais le sort comme
moi j'ai subi et vous le suivre même
subi ce même encore aujourd'hui c'est de
faire des enfants et de ne pas penser à
nous mêmes ça veut dire tous les ânes et
faire des enfants et bien quand tu veux
arrêter pourquoi tu t'arrêtes c'est vrai
je suis aussi croyant tant que le bon
dieu te donne des enfants que les prend
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui avec les
circonstances avec le contexte on peut
quand même les espaces et
alors bientôt vous recevrez les
allocations familiales sur votre compte
à vous demande ça fait encore un
scandale avec votre mari mais vous
obtenez une ordonnance de séparation un
appartement plus grand avec 5 et bientôt
le divorce j'ai beaucoup galéré avant
d'en arriver là on en arriver là mais
c'était une si j'ose dire une
consécration
d'une lutte personnelle
au sein d'un groupe qui ne comprenaient
pas c'est peut-être l'incompréhension et
ma frustration qui m'a poussé à me
révolter vous avez été très courageuse
je ne sais pas si je l'étais mais en
tout cas j'ai eu la force de tenir vous
êtes libérés
en quelque sorte oui
mais qu'un certain guy couach et vous le
le témoignage de khady sarr est vaste
aujourd'hui encore en 2005 on a des
femmes
qui sont des cités c'est pareil qui a
des civilités que justement c'est pas
des civilités et c'est toujours la femme
qui est la victime de tout
tout cas dans chaque société dans chaque
culture on cherche quelque part de nous
écraser
un chine avec les pieds en afrique avec
l'excision
les tchadors
voilà
alors aujourd'hui qu'à vivre militer
dans le monde entier contre l'excision
et l'infibulation
c'est encore pire tu viens là le sexe
est cousu encore pire parce que
l'infibulation on enlève le clitoris les
petites lèvres et les grandes lèvres et
ont joint les moignons en l'épousant
avec soit des épines d'acacia ou en les
faisant une bande au tour de cuisse pour
bien faire mais en laissant lé tout
petit orifice pour le sang menstruel et
les outils et ces femmes qu'ils ont subi
il n'y a pas longtemps une femme était
obligé d'être est ouverte pour avoir son
premier apport ce mal il y en a beaucoup
qui meurent de septicémie aussi il y en
a beaucoup qui meurt et a beaucoup de
deux conséquences néfastes médical du
côté médical et c'est pour ça d'où le
combat parce qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes
qui meurent en couches il faut beaucoup
lié certaine mortalité maternelle et
infantile via alexis alors en 1983 il ya
un arrêt de la cour de cassation
l'excision est puni de la cour d'assises
en risque vingt trente ans de de prison
mais en fait c'est pas appliquée parce
que il ya toujours des excisions et les
gens ne font pas vingt ou trente ans de
prison oui les gens ne font pas 20 ou 30
ans de prison mais il faut quand même
dire que les procès qui se sont
déroulées en france ont quand même
fait avancer la prévention et la
répression en même temps et ça a été
entendu parce que sur le territoire
français je peux pas dire c'est presque
disparu mais diront qu'il n'y a presque
plus d'exclusion sur le territoire
français en tout cas il ya un centre
auquel on peut s'adresser si on est dans
ce cas là si on est oui on peut
s'adresser à des associations notamment
moi je suis dans une association qui
s'appelle le guen ce groupe pour
l'abolition des mutilations sexuelles
qui travaille depuis 24 ans sur le sujet
ici en france il ya aussi la cance elle
elle est plutôt juridique c'est elle qui
s'occupe des procès la commission est
malheureusement en france il ya que le
games qui travaillent sur le terrain sur
le sujet en tout cas ouvertement
et en europe via le réseau européen que
je préside en ce moment qui regroupe
treize à quinze pays européens avec une
trentaine d'associations qui tout milite
contre les mutilations génitales
féminines et les mariages forcés et ce
qui est de moins en moins de mutilation
dans le monde où est-ce qu'il y en a
toujours autant finalement il y en a
moins même si les statistiques ne sont
pas encore fait il y en a moins parce
que quand même il ya un travail qui est
fait sur le terrain les associations
font un travail de fourmi comme vous
savez en afrique et les difficile
d'aller dans la brousse réelles et c'est
d'y aller et aujourd'hui à pas mal de
pays africains qui ont une loi
interdisant ça avec les associations il
ya aussi la prévention et des campagnes
de sensibilisation qui se fait
[Applaudissements]
kadi mutilé s'est plié aux éditions
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux